les modèles qu'on est vraiment jamais
trop tôt pour guider les patients dès
leur entrée dans cette clinique de laval
on trouve une ancienne infirmière
on a eu une formation dispensée par le
sis de laval donc à la demande du
gouvernement
on m'a sollicité pour vous défaire dans
le fond ici du triage donc ce triage des
patients carrément à la porte
marie-sophie l'heureux qui a délaissé la
profession il y à 12 ans est heureuse de
pouvoir aider à nouveau responsable de
la publication de l'association médicale
canadienne
elle travaille à domicile depuis des
années c'est à mon tour de de ne plus me
dit tenté d'être avec les gens et
honnêtement c'est énorme et ça me fait
vraiment du gué ça fait tellement
longtemps que je prends contact avec les
patients je me rends compte que ça m'a
manqué énormément au personnel du réseau
de la santé
vous êtes nos anges gardiens on compte
sur vous ces infirmières de l'hôpital
sainte justine et est retourné aux
études pour se spécialiser les mesures
annoncées vendredi pour la fermeture des
universités leur permettent de retourner
à l'hôpital
maintenant qu'on avait pu décosse est
elle juste naturel d'or venait
travailler mais je me suis dis go il
veut comme coralie t on voyait le stress
monte pour tout le personnel
elles ne sont pas les seuls à avoir le
sens du devoir du côté des personnes qui
ont de l'expérience ou de l'expertisé en
santé on est rendu à 10000 cv qu'on ne
reçut l'ordre des infirmières du québec
a assoupli les règles pour permettre aux
retraités ainsi qu aux infirmières qui
n'ont pas pratiqué au cours des quatre
dernières années de reprendre du service
notamment aux services ovi temps un je
partais travailler dans le milieu
hôtelier mais je veux aider au dépistage
jusqu'en 2016
diane sicard guindon a travaillé autant
comme soignante que comme gestionnaire
mais elle craint de ne pas être
sollicité parce qu'elle a 71 ans donc
elle est dans le groupe de la population
à risque pour faire appel à notre
jugement clinique et sow sarr et ce pour
les médecins spécialistes de quoi par
convenant lisez les dossiers s'ils
peuvent retourner alors je trouve que ça
devrait être la même chose pour les
infirmières le sens de la communauté
ghz et dans cette maison
intergénérationnelle où l'entr'aide en
pré séance
ainsi anne louise despatie radio canada